in 2018 the game candy crush made an
estimated four million dollars from
in-app purchases and microtransactions
per day and like most of the top
grossing mobile apps they sell useless
digital products to casual gamers in
today's video you'll learn how to
implement consumable in-app purchases
and flutter allowing you to sell your
own digital products on iOS or Android
via microtransactions not just doing
this for money if you're new you're like
and subscribe and you can find these
source code on fire ship io and congrats
to andrei hava you won the t-shirt from
last week sweater video let's start by
talking about how in-app purchases work
from a high level and how to use them
successfully in your app the first thing
you should know is that there are three
main types of in-app purchases
consumables are products that are
depleted that can be purchased multiple
times like coins in a game in Summa
bowls are what we're focused on in this
video and we'll build a feature that
allows the user to buy some gems consume
them and then buy some more the second
type is a non consumable which is
something the user purchases once like
an upgrade and then should never have to
purchase it again in the future and the
third type is a subscription which gives
the user access to the purchase for a
limited amount of time now these
concepts apply to both iOS and Android
but there are some subtle yet important
differences that we'll look at when we
get into the code in a few minutes and
another thing you should know about
in-app purchases is that they're almost
always required if you're selling
digital content that means API is like
stripe and PayPal are out of the
question
but luckily flutter just recently
released an officially supported plugin
for in-app purchases that provides a
unified interface across iOS and Android
that's what we'll be using in this video
but it is currently in beta so things
may change in the future now when it
comes to making millions of dollars per
day you need to build an app that's both
highly addictive and that targets a wide
audience you should design your
interface around dopamine hits and
compulsion loops in other words reward
the user on a regular basis but always
keep them chasing the dragon so now that
you know how to design your app let's go
ahead and get into the technical details
the first thing we'll take care of is
the initial setup for both iOS and
Android for iOS you'll need to have an
Apple Developer account and
making the assumption that you have a
release of your iOS app on App Store
connect it doesn't need to be on the
public App Store just App Store connect
for use with things like test flight
there are a lot of small but easy steps
involved with that that are beyond the
scope of this video but the flutter
documentation has a detailed guide for
preparing an iOS release and I also have
a video that covers it in my full
flutter course in App Store connect
we'll go to the features tab add a new
in-app purchase making sure that it's a
consumable type then we'll give it a
name and a Product ID and we want to
keep a note of this Product ID because
we want that to be the same on the
Google Play Store and everything else is
just the pricing and display details for
your actual product so now that we have
our product will go into Xcode and
enable the in-app purchases capability
select the build target go to the
capabilities tab and then flip the
in-app purchases switch to on so that
takes care of the Apple App Store now
let's switch gears to Android and the
Google Play Store at this point I'm
assuming that you have a Google Play
Developer account and you'll also need
to go through the steps to create a
signed release that can be uploaded to
Google Play and once again there are a
lot of easy steps involved beyond the
scope of this video so refer to the
flutter documentation or the full
flutter course once you create the
actual signed apk you'll need to create
at least an alpha release for your app
and that will allow you to test the
Google Play billing API locally on your
device that Google billing API simply
won't work if you don't have a release
created for your app and you'll also
want to add your email address as a
tester on that track from there we'll go
to the store presence tab then to in-app
products and then go to manage products
now on Google Play you don't actually
select a distinction between consumable
and non consumable instead you handle
that directly in the app and we'll see
how that works in the source code in
just a minute for now we'll go ahead and
create a new product with the same
product ID that we used on iOS now make
sure to set your product to active and
then everything else should be pretty
self-explanatory now that we have the
initial set up out of the way we can
start developing our flutter app now I
want to start by saying that the code
I'm about to show you focuses on the API
of the in-app purchases plugin I want to
keep the implementation details as unup
enya nated as possible so I'm only using
the tools that are built into flutter
but this is a type of feature that could
benefit from things like provider block
or firebase to manage the state of your
purchases across multiple devices and
screens but I'll leave those decisions
up to you I just want to show you how to
build a Minimum Viable Product using
nothing but a stateful widget the first
thing we'll do is add the plug
to our pups Becky Amal then we'll go
ahead and import it in our dart file
along with IO so we can do platform
checking I'm calling this the market
screen and let's start by looking at the
different properties or state available
on the switch --it first we'll make a
reference to the in-app purchase
connection instance which gives us
access to all of the API methods in the
plug-in that will just keep our code
nice and concise the first part of the
initialization process is to check if
the API is actually available on this
device then we'll set up a list that
keeps the product details that we query
from the Google Play Store or the Apple
App Store and then also a set of
purchase details that gives us the users
past purchases then we'll also set up a
subscription that listens to a stream of
updates to the purchase details so this
stream will emit a new value when the
user buys a product in the app or if
they buy a product from a different
client and lastly I have a placeholder
for credits which is just used to
represent the consumable product in this
demo now moving on to the lifecycle
hooks during an it state we're going to
fetch the products and purchases from
the corresponding marketplace and that
stuff is all asynchronous so we'll move
it into its own method and we also have
a stream on this widget so we'll want to
make sure to cancel it now the next
thing we'll look at is the actual UI
itself which is very simple in this case
we have a scaffold with an app bar that
will either display open for business or
not available depending on whether or
not the in-app purchases API is
available from there we'll loop over the
products that we fetch from the
marketplace and then for each product
we'll need to determine if the user has
a past purchase for it if they have
purchased a product then we'll create
some custom logic to allow them to
consume it otherwise we'll just go ahead
and display a button that allows them to
make a new purchase this is just a bare
minimum UI example so you'll definitely
want to customize it to fit within your
own app now the next major hurdle that
we'll tackle is initializing all the
data in this widget we'll do that with
an async method called initialize that
we call during the net state lifecycle
hook first we'll check to see if the API
is available and then if so we'll go
ahead and retrieve the products and the
users past purchases and I've moved that
logic into individual private methods
just so we get a clear picture of all
the steps involved and I'm sure someone
will call me out on this so instead of
awaiting products and then awaiting
purchases you can do it concurrently by
using future wait and add both of them
together in a list and that will run
them concurrently for a better
performance now just because you have
retrieved a purchase does not
necessarily mean that it's valid
so we'll also need to implement some
business logic to verify a purchase and
then throughout the lifecycle of the app
the user will hopefully purchase
additional products so we'll want to set
up a subscription to the purchase
updated stream this stream will emit a
list of newly created purchase details
so when the stream emits a new value we
can take those new purchases and then
append them to the existing list on this
widget what you don't want to do is
override the existing list because the
stream only emits new purchases so
that's just something to keep in mind so
now let's look at the implementation
details for this data retrieval first we
get products which is no different than
making an API call or reading from a
firestore document we just create a set
of the product IDs that we want to
retrieve from either the App Store or
the Google Play Store and then we run in
app purchases query product details
that's going to give us a response and
then we can check that response for
errors or to see if any of the product
IDs are missing but for the sake of
simplicity we'll call set state and set
the products equal to the response
product details so that gives us our
products for sale now we need to get the
users past purchases this is a very
similar process but instead we call
query past purchases but there's one
major caveat and this method does not
return consumed products because they
consumed product can be purchased
multiple times it's not going to be
returned by this method that means you
need to save the state of a consumed
product in your database that's the only
way the user will be able to retrieve it
after this widget has been destroyed so
getting past purchases from the actual
marketplace itself is really only
relevant for non consumable products but
one of the caveat that you should know
about is if you retrieve past purchases
you'll also want to mark them as
complete on iOS now if you do have a
consumable product it will be 100% your
own business logic to retrieve it if
this were my app I would be using
firebase so I would most likely retrieve
it from the firestore database in any
case the final step here is to call set
state and set the purchases list on this
widget now the next thing we need to do
is figure out if a user has purchased a
specific product in this case I'm just
going to create a helper method that
takes a Product ID as its argument and
then that loops through the purchases
list to see if we have any matching IDs
if we have a match then we'll go ahead
and return the purchase details
otherwise we'll return null now the next
method is also going to be 100% your own
business logic that will take a purchase
and then actually deliver it in the app
itself in this demo we only have a
single
product so we're going to see if that
user has purchased the product and we'll
also go ahead and make sure that that
purchase is valid these status can also
be error or pending so we wouldn't want
to deliver the credits or the gems to
the app if the user hasn't fully paid
you'll want to verify purchases both
when the app is initialized and then
also when a new purchase is emitted
through that purchase updated stream and
you may even want to do that server-side
so at this point we have all of the
necessary data loaded into our widget
and now we need to give the user away to
purchase a product as well as consume a
product inside of our products loop
we'll have access to individual product
details which we can then pass to this
by-product method to create a purchase
per Ram that will send the necessary
data over to the corresponding
marketplace and then because Android
doesn't make the distinction between
consumable and non consumable you need
to do that when you purchase the product
so for one-time purchases you'll use by
non consumable but in our case we want
the user to buy this multiple times so
we'll say buy consumable now by default
it will be marked as consumed
automatically which means it's up to
your own business logic to control the
state of that purchase however I would
like to point out that you can set Auto
consume to false which only applies to
Android and that will prevent the user
from purchasing that product again until
you actually mark it as consumed and we
can actually demonstrate how that works
with our next method here called spend
credits it takes the purchase details as
its argument and then it will decrement
the credits on this widget every time
the user taps a button when the user
runs out of credits or when they equals
zero we'll go ahead and tell the Google
Play Store that that purchase has been
consumed and that will allow the user to
purchase another instance of this
product otherwise they'll get an error
that they already own this product and
that's all there is to it we now have
all the pieces in place to sell our
users an infinite number of useless gems
and we just need to refine our dopamine
hits and compulsion loops to start
making millions of dollars per day if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member on fire ship IO to get access to
the full flora chorus and a bunch of
other exclusive content thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]